Learning happens best when your child gives you good eye contact.
Today we're going to teach you some fun ways...
...to encourage your child to give you eye contact.
Hold your child's favorite toy up next to your eyes.
This will draw your child's attention to the object and therefore your face.
Don't give the child the object until they have given you eye contact.
Put on a mask or funny glasses using something bright,  colorful...
...or a bit silly in your face will encourage your child to look at you.
Play peekaboo with your child.
Use different objects such as a scarf or your hands...
...to cover your face.
Allow your child to pull the object away and then say "boo!"
Blow up a balloon with your child.
Wait for your child to give you eye contact...
...before you blow it up a little bit more each time.
You can also practice eye contact at the playground.
Prepare your child for a swing but don't let them start swinging...
...until they look at you.